all right back to John in North Carolina
it was $30,000 on his truck $9,000 on
his wife's Subaru makes a hundred and
fifty thousand his wife and him I aren't
exactly on the same page but he's
thinking how can he best serve his
family considering maybe selling the
truck and that's about how far we got in
the discussion right John yeah okay I
was just looking at all my notes here
I'm trying my buddies yelling mess let's
be in the truck but you know I got time
I got eleven five in credit cards two
different credit cards and I started you
back in May I think we had like 12
credit cards she have 11,500 and credit
card debt what other dad have you got I
got a house I just refinance it so other
than the house and the two and the two
cars and the credit cards what have you
got I did okay alright and so what would
be wrong with you and your wife sitting
down and saying we're gonna live on a
written plan with our great income of a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars and
we're going to plow through fifty
thousand dollars worth of debt in the
next year to 18 months that is the plan
that she's just kind of discouraged he
does I started to work a job she was I
don't know we argue about his finances
she just started a job next week she's
gonna be starting the job yeah but why
are you alright what are you arguing
about
well I don't know she wants a better
vehicle to once she has a damaged it's
having some mechanical issues okay and
she's kind of tired of it now I mean
we've also been doing this six months we
went from eating out every weekend
buying stuff did you know nothing won't
you give her your truck and you draw the
Subaru I have thought about that too
just till we cared to drive it do what
she says she scared the drivers she
wrecked my old truck I think I'm
announcing nothing wrong with that but
yeah how old are you - 30 years old okay
alright well I think the thing you got
to do is address this and it sounds like
that she's tired
of fighting through you've been working
on for six months and she's using the
Subaru is something to whine about and
that's what I do when I get tired of
wine and so you know you could give her
your truck why don't you just sound and
say okay what's it take to get you going
cuz we're not gonna go further in debt
while we're getting out of debt
do I need to sell my truck so I can get
you a better car and or or do you want
to drive my truck for a little while so
you feel good again while we work this
out because we can pay all of this off
in under two years if we just stay on it
and show her the mountain started the
second job myself
I'll make by 200 the weekend doing
flooring and I have a military
retirement that I get about thousand
bucks a month doing that yeah but you've
got all of that focused on your every
dollar budget and both of you are
looking at the budget but she's just
tired right yes I believe so and I love
her to death I wanted to be happy
there's a two-way Road I wanted to be
happy but I don't want to have to give
her stuff for her to be happy that's not
the point
she just needs to she needs to say out
loud what it's going to take for her to
take a deep breath and plow through the
next 18 months because you'll be free in
18 months
if you keep plowing now does she need to
drive your truck or do you need to sell
your truck and get her a better car and
get you a lesser truck what do you what
do we got to do honey let's talk it
through because we got to play through
we got to finish the game the game is
getting tough right now we got to finish
the game for Christmas and winter time
I'm getting less hours to skin tight
that's all yeah but you should be able
to cover all of that in the budget you
make plenty of money shouldn't be tight
it shouldn't be I agree man if you're
not paying X if you're doing a written
plan with the kind of money you tell me
you're making annually you should not be
tight even when things slow down a
little bit it just means you're putting
less on the debt is all but you're still
gonna have Christmas and you're still
gonna have food you still gonna have
lights and water your house frame is
still gonna be paid alright then I guess
that's what we'll do I got one quick
question you guys are gonna simply
listen you guys are not sitting down and
doing the written budget together every
month before the month begins or
you well I mean my son do it she doesn't
really want to do it that's what I mean
my son will do it he's 10 your son is
not the problem
okay the two of you have to sit down and
lay out a game plan that you're both in
agreement to no one wants to sacrifice
randomly out in space the only reason
someone sacrifices is to win and they
have to be able to see the light at the
end the tunnel that's not an oncoming
train
so the fact that she's not plugged into
the budget is where her lack of energy
is coming from on this and so the two of
you have got to sit down together you're
never gonna win it money until you do
that let's try this I'm gonna put you
both through Financial Peace University
I'm gonna pay for it if I give you the
class you and her both have to go to the
class it's nine weeks long one night a
week you're both going and I'll pay for
it doesn't cost you a thing the only
thing I have to have from you as a
commitment that both of you will attend
the class I'll have put you on hold
Kelly will pick up if you give her that
commitment I will pay for the two of you
to go through the class and that'll help
get you aligned on this you're gonna
struggle until you get aligned